hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we were doing an extremely highs a
requested video this is the what's on my
iPhone 7 plus I thought I had done one
business that I guess I have it and
probably the reason why if I recently
reset my phone so when I went to do this
video I had nothing on my phone I had
over 35,000 photos and videos so I
backed that up I deleted everything and
I started over and started fresh and now
my phone is running so fast legit like
brand new
we'll just arm from the top I've got my
calendars my cloth my note in my app
store Apple maps and Google Maps my
settings Twitter Facebook phone YouTube
which is very important throughout to
get your video app which is basically
good for creators it allows you to go in
you go to dashboard videos analytic
without Instagram if you want to follow
me on Instagram it's not just seeing
clips this is a super cool video I made
a video about this before it's a whole
kind of simple solution to creating cool
little square clip snapchat following I
just need this Spotify we've got my
gmail and snow have you guys used snow
because if you have and pop on it right
now and follow your girl I just this is
actually me
Mima right now am I on Friday well it's
kind of a location check-in place it
used to be called Foursquare but then
swarm broke off of Foursquare and became
swarm best fiends and a full disclosure
this video is sponsored by best fiends
and here's something that is so crazy I
have had so many of my friend do videos
about best fiends I've had some of my
friends in the commercial for best
fiends and just recently they send me an
email today why don't you check out this
game and see what you think if you're
interested let us know if you guys have
been around for a while these types of
games where you do the swiping and color
matching thing it's my weakness with
these types of games I know myself and I
know that if I'm super busy I need to
like set some sort of parental
restrictions on my phone because I know
all I'm going to want to do is play this
and I just started playing it this week
so they just launched today or yesterday
or depending upon when you're watching
me basically the slugs go to boot camps
they have this super cute animation it's
kind of like a little digital short
they've got some incredible voice actors
Kate Walsh the mom from 13 reason why he
has Mark freakin Hamill
I think this looks like it could have
been a film like a movie I bet you they
are probably going to be doing a movie
and if they're not this is a great idea
for you guys I'm going to offer that to
you and you need a voice please let me
be a voice let me be a slug are there
any blonde slogans that there's not I'm
your girl I'm about to beat uncle please
I want to be a voice and that's how I
get a job at ledges ask for it here we
go we just do this
I just got back from Yosemite and this
is where I started playing it so as
you're like driving through this
beautiful scenery I'm like sitting in
the backseat just like so this is it
it's kind of like a little puzzle game
you match the things it's free to play I
also have a link in the description
where you guys can get four dollars
worth of diamonds and gold I need to be
more strategic oh the pain is the bomb
went off I only have six moves less and
have to defeat two more slow so I can do
it incredible move haha this is core
level 44 I just connected this to my
facebook so this is great so I can see
where my friends are there's Jenna at
Lamar it is oh my gosh Lamar is ahead of
me oh no I'm staying up all night Lamar
I'm not going to be letting you beat me
so moving on we've got the penguins app
which hello I'm from Pittsburgh
I am penguins proud and I am hoping that
my pen win the Stanley Cup this year
this is taking a lot longer to go
through a few apps than I thought even
though the DJI Gulf 4 app which is very
important if you have a Maddox throne or
one of the phantom fours because this is
the aperture with youth to do that let's
see what I've been droning about oh wow
this even when I was flying with a DJI
goggles Starbuck very very important and
it's very near and dear to my heart the
Amazon asks something that I used a lot
it's also prime now which is right next
to that and that's something that is not
in all cities but in bigger cities it
allows you to basically order things
within an hour so know that allows me to
basically control the music all through
my house I have different speakers and
they all connect to Wi-Fi playing play
music wherever I
so no sticker um chickens yell chicken
scream I forget what that was called
yeah chicken scream is crazy it's
basically like flappy bird but you
control it with your voice well mate
that's also something that's very
important since if I didn't have it I
would be starving Q this is cool so I'll
show you I can change color
oh my life I think this is the one that
I had yeah it looks good spring blossom
I like this Arctic Aurora we're going to
keep that one YouTube TV this is pretty
cool it's also not in all areas but you
can watch live television too through
this subscription so just all live TV
shows specially of caffeine this
actually isn't even out yet so if you
guys want to check it out as caffeine TV
I've been working with them for a while
they do really really awesome
low-latency live streaming for video
games so instant it actually blows my
mind like the first time they showed me
a demo and said can you guys show me
that again mention stuff like Facebook's
app for verified users we've got nest
there's a facebook Messenger OpenTable
that's what I used to make restaurant
reservations the IndyCar Series apps
maybe 500 is actually this weekend and
I'm still sad that I'm not there I went
for the past two years best of luck to
everyone this weekend I wish you all
well and be safe
gosh Racing is so dangerous credit wise
Capital One I use that to check my
credit can you know what something that
my parents told me ever since I was very
very young is how important credit is
and I didn't listen we got face tune and
I think this is what a lot of the beauty
bloggers use to get their perfect
glowing complexion but mostly what I use
I like to have very white backgrounds in
my pictures so for example I'll use this
what you're supposed to use to whiten
your teeth and I will use this to whiten
backgrounds of my Instagram photos over
not everywhere through the audible if
you guys have any good audible
suggestions of books for me to listen to
leave those in the comments below
Southwest because I travel a lot play
memory jobs this is actually an app by
Sony and I use that to get photos off my
camera this is my extras folder I got my
compass tips voice memo contacts fine
friends fine
well numbers iMovie pages basically all
the things that Apple just automatically
throws on your phone so I gave them
their own folder of nonsense calculators
all all like this really all went
tumbler verbo is actually so cool I have
an unboxing video this coming out is a
dog treat dispenser and a webcam and
it's so cool in Francesca got it since
my birthday so very very soon that will
be on my channel
FedEx app so that I can know when I have
packages ring it's a doorbell people
ring and then I can get it on my phone
Apple store we've got the period plus
app which I don't think I need to go
into any detail about that soon this is
an app that you can get on-demand
massages to room your house yeah
JetBlue I fly JetBlue a lot when I'm
going to New York and I've been spending
a lot of time there recently so that has
been coming in quite handy drop-off for
storing files Juneau is also another
uber type app and also use that a lot in
New York Sun paper this happens really
cool it will show you where the Sun is
and will show you where the Sun is e so
if you're outside filming it's so cool
to be able to say oh if I wait 20
minutes this one will actually be behind
my building and we can get our shot
these XQ apps are ones that I have for
future videos and I'm doing with dr. oz
ResMed it's like a sleep tracker thing
it's kind of cool it also comes with a
suit tracker for your bedside more about
that later these next few or meditation
apps I've only done headspace before
when I was doing the consistent daily
meditation I felt so good like I'm not
just being crazy and saying that like I
did and I need to start doing it again
breathe and calm I have a try build one
yet the headspace was so great I'll Yelp
for food reviews and restaurant
recommendations live solo a live
streaming app blue bar this one is
pretty insane it's like an augmented
reality app but it's like fine things
and it like knows what they are here's
what's also very scary it just found me
if they thinks I'm wearing four clothes
that I'm not blonde look at this look at
the things that it's saying can you
believe it saw my face and it knew who I
was
we've got wash OS which is a company
that does on-demand car washes yeah put
the thing
SoundCloud visco
ham which is great it's just a really
super intense kind of photo editing app
which I feel like everybody who's a
photographer or anybody who's anybody
uses this and last but not least we've
got saucy just an alcohol delivery app I
feel like if you live in a big city you
can do everything from the palm of your
hand do you want food do you want drink
massage I guess last but not least is
the Sodom what you guys have been seeing
the whole side we've got messages mail
Safari and the camera so that what goes
on my iPhone 7 plus I hope you guys
enjoyed it let me know if you guys have
a favorite app or any games or anything
else that you guys think that I should
try out leave those in the comments
below and I will see you in the next
video I think I'm losing my voice we
shot like six videos today this is like
my seventh one I'm exhausted man have I
got some cool stuff for you guys coming
up in the next few weeks like some crazy
stuff I've ever done on my channel will
be on my channel so great I'll see you
later stay tuned it's going to be fun
[Music]